hello everyone and welcome to the last
game I'll be uploading today but not the
last game I'll be uploading from round
one of the world rabbit championship
I'll give you a give you a break so you
can you know I catch up on all the
videos it's all it has a future with the
white pieces against the unchurched of
Duda at both of them on three and a half
points so three wins and only one draw
Ali there's a two down Anton horrible in
round three and Sergey Kerrigan in round
four and now he faces Duda so without
further ado let's check it out it's a
it's a really awesome game with the
white pieces are Lisa opens with E for
that we have these six going for for the
pierced defense which can be quite
dangerous especially in shorter time
formats but Duda enjoys sharp positions
and he wants to get you know winning
chances regardless of playing black or
white with d4 with Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and g6 now and always that goes
for f4 the Austrian attack with Bishop
to g7 knife to f3 with castles and
Bishop to d3 so the main line of the
Austrian attack Knight to c6 and E 5 now
with characters captures and Knights to
d5 with captures the Knights get traded
off you don't have to worry about losing
your queen since g6 was played and Queen
to e2 with Bishop to g4 and now you
don't have time for a slow move since
the bishop to d4 is the threat with a
double attack on the knight and the
Queen so here we have Bishop the e4
aware as a pushes the Queen back Queen
to a5 check Bishop to b2 and Queen to b6
putting pressure on the b2 pawn here we
have bush of the c3 and rook a to d8 and
it's interesting Duda didn't really lose
any time on all of his moves and you
know playing playing the Pierce
against a strong player like if Rosa
knows that he means that he's extremely
well prepared
whereas ali reza took some time playing
out all of these moves and here queen 2
f2 is the strongest move and is the move
that it's pretty much always played in
this position but oh it is a place h3
and this allows Duda some very nice
ideas so here do that first captures on
f3 we have Bishop captures Queen
actress and night the d4 now just
attacking the Queen and also you you
don't want to give up your dark square
bishop sense without it it's gonna be
really difficult not only to attack the
black King but you do need it to you
know help out with the defense
so Queen to g3 and now just f6 and by
Duda and here it's a really difficult at
the find safety for your King if you
Castle kingside well it's just lost you
go under the the mask of the Queen so in
any nasty discovery will window Queen
for example if you if you Castle
queenside then you just lose the Queen
right away it's just you know a nice
fort and also if you say okay I really
don't have anything can I just give up
my dark square Bishop no you can't
because after Luke captures your Bishop
is hanging and once you move the bishop
then you get F captures on e5 and the
position explodes it doesn't really
matter what you do captures Bishop h6 is
coming now hunter Brooke controls the F
file the bishop controls this diagonal
you're not castling kingside or Queen
side and well you're just getting
getting you know crushed here so after
f6 Carosa decides for Bishop to d3
causes of causes of the the D file but
now F captures on e5 opening up the
position now again if F captures Bishop
h6 and you don't have any any any any
moves left to play here black can just
play whatever black wants so here
nowadays I decided to give up the pawn
and Castle queenside now as if you don't
Castle now you're not gonna Castle at
all he captures an F for grabbing yet
another pawn so now it's well 7 points 7
to 5 so do dice up two points Queen to
g4 and now Queen to c5 preparing to
bring the knight back to guard the d7
pawn but also to open up and attack
towards the bishop here so we look HD 1
and now just Knight to c6 defending the
pawn once again and also threatening
just Bishop captures in c3 so
Queen the e6 check by Frazier King h8
and now Bishop captures in g7 with King
captures and King to b1 just getting the
King to a safer Square and
do that still up dew points but the
position has opened up nicely problem
for white is that white no longer has
the dark square bishop to be used for
attack and it's gonna be it's gonna be
very hard attacking on the white squares
so rook to f6 pushing the Queen back
Queen to g4 and now Knight to e5
attacking the Queen and the bishop we
have Queen to g5 hoping for some tricks
because if Knight captures and d3 Queen
captures Knight captures but you lose
the road can be 8 so now here just rook
to d5 now there are some nasty
discoveries threatens here of course
Bishop to e2 offering a trade of rooks
but now without even pausing the video
of course you see Knight to d3 a nice
discovery that threatens the Queen and
also the rock on e1 and this is where
the the fun really starts here
viraja gives up the Queen Queen captures
on d5 with Queen captures on d5 and now
not capturing the knight right away but
first Bishop to f3 kicking away the
Queen and now it's it's perfectly fine
to move away the Queen and then
recapture on d3 and you have a bishop
and the rook against the Queen so you
will you will of course try to hold this
but do the place something remarkable he
plays Queen captures on f3 he gives the
Queen back point being that if G
captures you get Knight captures rook
captures and after king f7 defending you
have again 6 points to 5 it's a
completely winning game for black and do
that is very confident that he will
convert to the two extra points so ali
reza decides for rook captures on e7
instead he will grab yet another pawn
before trading queens we have king to f8
the only move you have to you know make
a move with tempo with an attack on the
rook G captures on f3 and now King
captures on e7 and here rook captures on
b3 CC captures and III is the only way
to continue the game however you know
you were down upon you you don't want to
mess up your pawn structure even further
so here all it is a plate rook captures
on d3 but it now is just completely lost
so feel free to pause the video now and
try to find the winning move for Duda in
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it
congratulations on knowing your end
games and for those of you who just want
to enjoy show rook the d6 this is what I
do the plate and it was in this position
unmoved 31 that Alireza furiosa resigned
the game and he took his first loss of
the tournament whereas Duda continues
going for four and a half out of five
and he joins the leaders of the
tournament here it's well it's not
playable if you move the rook you get
made it that's the point that's why all
it as a resign and if you trade rooks it
doesn't really help you captures
captures and of course you have to know
that the King and pawn endgame is
winning simply it takes very very few
moves for for black to clean up these
pawns and white just doesn't have any
counter play so it's basically enough to
just let's say pick up the H pawn the
defend this guy and put the H point to
victory there's nothing nothing white
can do about that so really really
insane stuff and it's really really even
more impressed with that after Bishop to
have to redo that decided to go for this
Queen captures on f3 I mean yes of
course you are you're a very strong run
through you are confident in your
endgame skills but still giving up a
queen like that just not something not
something you see is see very often not
not something I don't think it's
something anyone would do so that's why
that's what makes it even more
impressive but yeah before we forget we
do have the standings after five rounds
like I said we are going to show at
least a couple of more games from round
one so here there are with four and a
half points oh one cow ileus million
chakram a media of a young sister of
Duda and linear Dominguez so five of
them with four and a half points
followed by four points Magnus cross and
gather Hussein of Alexander's above
laQuan Liam the new loop of Alexander
moti live and Maxine was Sheila graph
those are with four points then with
three and a half Daniel Friedman Alex a
sheer of onigiri Alexander areas ancef
11 RN and Paulo punk rat of Paco Vallejo
Yanni Pony she Alexander Greece shock
from city invoke sheet of Nicky DeVito
gov Peter Svidler and grant and
Melkonyan
so those are the top 25 players and you
can see all of them are grandmasters and
even one international master made it to
the top 25 samson inbox evocative so
there we have it those are the standings
I do hope you enjoyed that and that
you've enjoyed this game tough break for
for alga Reza now losing a game with the
white pieces but you know you can't win
more and it's really impressive how do
the really really a sharp player goes
for the Pierce against such such an
aggressive player like like Kali Reza
really really enjoyed that but yeah I
would like to thank dog McNab Edward
Baker Maxime piece an inch in 1998 and
torrents fight for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here they will be
from this tournament of course and we
are going to cover more of the game from
round one and we are continuing the
coverage for the next four days from the
world rapid and blitz championship so I
think Oh once again and I will see you
soon with what what we've just discussed
so have an excellent rest of your day